You know, it's not easy being me right?
Not only am I a gamer
the most oppressed group on the Internet. (nothing new of course)
I'm also PewDiePie, oppressed by mainstream media, left and right.
I fought all these battles.
and here I am
getting attacked when, when I'm at the weakest.
Finally
I have met my match
T-Series is taking over. (its a hard knock life.)
it's inevitable at this point
#Pewdiepieisoverparty
Is this what oppression feels like? Is this what it means?
Then I don't like it.
Okay?
So let's look at other people being oppressed, so I can feel better about myself.
Yes of course I'm talking about...
Tumblr In Action
So we can look at other people having a hard life, and feel better about ourselves. gottem.
"Oppressed by H&M's mirrors"
THIS IS SO SAD!
"Dear H&M this image of two mirrors in your store
on the right is my normal "efrection"
*REFLECTION*
on the left you can clearly see I'm- I'm shorter and fatter"
OPPRESSION!!!
(epic meme)
Dear H&M,
as you can see from these photos, the perspective or the reflections make me look bigger if I'm closer to the object.
How does this work?
Dear H&M, can you please fix the laws of physics?
This is so sad
This kid literally brought a jug of water to class
and is just drinking out of it (stay hydrated kids)
I hate college and I hate why... *laughs*
Now the question here is:
do they hate them separately, alright?
Or do they hate them individua- or like, collectively?
Because of this person, you know, it's not really clear. Imagine- Imagine coming home from- from college,
you're still living at home,
you come in a really bad mood like *erghgehr*
Your parents are like, "honey, what happened?"
"You wouldn't believe MOM,
my day is ruined; someone drank water out of a jug".
Your mom is just stay there shocked.
I hate white people too, good job.
You know, SUDDENLY, me complaining about T-Series doesn't feel so bad, what else do we have?
Becoming disabled by choice,
Trans-abled,
*Visible confusion*
What?
No
People are becoming disabled on purpose and calling themselves transable.
Why does this exist?
Who came up with this?
it's a mental illness. Yeah. It must be a mental illness...
Apple Emoji finally acknowledged that women work out, too *rocking back and forth in mental pain*
*laughs* This makes me hate the world!
*CLAP*
WHY DOES THIS EXIST?
STOP IT!
This is not real. This is not real. Can we...
Oh God, it's real. Ugh...
Ugh, it makes me sick.
"Women run, lift weights and surf and-"
Oh man...
*CLAP* *CLAP*
They finally did it, guys
Apple, finally
Finally, this giant company that I buy my overpriced cellphone- phones
acknowledge the fact that women exercise.
This is a big day.
This is amazing
We truly run out of things to celebrate
I didn't know what I was gonna find today. But this is this is beautiful
Motherboard
another fantastic new media website
guess how many women
Elon Musk follows on Twitter
Hint: same number of people currently on Mars
I use Twitter for news organizations. My insta has same women as men.
This is not real
This can't be real
no no no no n-no no no n- *laughs*
Oh My god
I thought- I thought the articles of me were petty but this is just-
this is just next-level
It's not a real thing are you do a bit I can't tell a question mark
The term spirit animal is deeply religious and is- and using it is cultural appropriation
Please use "patronus" instead
*Headphone users* Mute
Okay, all right, all right, I've read it it's already made me laugh let me explain it
HART MAIN started
He was fed up with his sisters candles from being all flowery smelly
So he created man cans with candles that smell like campfire and coffee
and he made them out of soup cans
So he would donate the soup to homeless people
while still selling the kids the candles
and he sold 80,000 of them which means 80,000 people got a meal
and Tumblr's take on this is
I'm not behind this still a white boy re- boy reinforcing gender stereotypes
I don't give a CRAP how good of a person he is
I'm pretty sure there are some (r word) out there who have donated to charities or done something good
Hitler's family probably thought he was a great person
misogyny is still misogyny
Did you just compare a 17 year old boy who fed their homeless to Hitler
Tumblr: everyone is Hitler!
Pro t- Pro tip here's a- here's a pro tip for you guys, alright
This is a pro tip from the tumblr-verse
don't learn a language If you do not come from the languages bearers
i.e; don't learn French if you're not French
don't learn chinese, if you're not Chinese
don't learn Icelandic if you're not Icelandic
It just appropriates culture more
what would be ideal here
If everyone just stayed away from each other at all times. Okay
that must be a whoosh, isn't it? It's a whoosh
did I just get whooshed
It must be a joke, right? This can't be real but everything else has been real
And it's from tumblr
Tumblr can't make jokes about themselves.
Hey, they say it as well. You know, what's messed up about the cultural appropriation nonsense
It's just ridiculous. I can't tell if it's satire or sarcas-
ME NEITHER!
Well, this actually kind of makes sense
Okay. So here's the difference between social activists and social justice warriors
Social activists. "Oh, look, there's no wheelchair ramps in that building. Let's build a ramp!"
Social justice warrior: "let's persecute the people using the stairs and make them feel bad for having legs"
How dare you have legs?
Don't you see these stairs? You're not thinking about the trans-able people
How are they gonna walk up these stairs when they remove their legs, huh? You tell me. you disgusting
Look I d- I never want to pull out my  "I have a comparative Women's Studies degree centered in black feminist and-
womanologist-
woman womanist?-
ideology
with a concentration in media"
Debate language out on y'all
But y'all be pushing me there
don't make her pull out her useless degree
again, Is it real is it real?
It's a comparative Women's Studies degree centered in black feminist woman- womanist
ideology with concentration in media.
I have so many questions
I'm just confused. Where are these people?
Where are they? I never see them. I just see them online
This is gender neutral this is gender neutral this is possibly the farthest away you can get from gender neutral
I just like this comment saying I'm raising my baby
chaotic neutral
Because they're the most interest
It's a vagana not feminine. Why are there so many gay men who don't date a woman
Just because she has a vagana
like that is stupid disCRIMINATION
We're so deep into social justice that being gay is now discrimination
We did it guys, we finally came full circle
Full circle and beyond!
oh my god! this video! I saw it
I think me and  Ethan were the reason this video were pulled because after our video ,we reviewed it ,and it got deleted
YouTube pulls
controversial music video with graphic
homosexual sex after it racked up
700,000 views
Controversial let's s- let me see if I get it
It's a controversial video with graphic sex but it's totally normal video with the women almost naked
Dancing sensual moves then it's okay.
No, they literally eat each other's poopoo
That's controversial
Trying to make- trying to write a joke that won't offend anyone on tumblr
This is the worst point I have ever seen
if you have trouble making jokes that aren't  racist to everybody
Misogynistic then you are funny. Actually.
Do you want to build a snow person?
Fine alright, maybe T series is taking over-
my chanel isn't such a big deal after all
smash subscribe so we can take over the Indians
No oppression intended
Okay, I'm sorry
But we can't let them win
smash subscribe so we can still be the biggest
Most subscribed channel on YouTube
leave a like if you enjoyed this video and I will see you tomorrow with another video
What's he gonna come up with next?
You're just gonna have to find out tomorrow. See you then. Bye
[Music]